So now that he's all cleaned up,...
...let me introduce you to our van, Ody, which by the way is short for Odysseus.
He's a 38-year-old Mercedes 307D Sprinter van with rear-wheel drive, a diesel engine,...
...and a top speed of 90 km/h.
I know, really fast.
Oh and he has a knack for getting stuck.
We wanted an old van because we really liked the look of those old Sprinters...
...and they are way cheaper than the newer ones.
Plus we decided to convert our van into an off-grid camper entirely on our own,...
...so that we could learn as much as possible.
I mean, there are so many skills when you do a full van conversion.
And a lot of those would come in super handy...
...when we build our own self-sustaining off-grid home one day...
...or at least that's our 10-year plan.
Yeah, I think we used up already half of the stuff, so one more.
What a day.
That was really fun.
I like working on the van with you.
Alright, should I get started?
Sure!